-We met at a heart attack
factory, "SNL"...
-Yeah.
-...when you hosted in 2001.
And you went back recently
to play Rex Tillerson.
There you go. Sadly...
[ Cheers and applause ]
He was not long for
the administration, though.
This will not be
a gravy train for you.
-No.
-He's already done.
-The fine paychecks,
the fat paychecks you get
off being an extra on "SNL."
-When you played -- that's true.
Of course,
during the Lewinsky scandal,
you played Linda Tripp famously.
-Yeah.
-How many times do you think you
played her over the course...
-I thought one too many.
But apparently they liked it.
-They kept bringing you back.
-So they kept writing
little capers for me.
I just thought it was because
I looked cute in a dress.
-You did.
I think everybody -- did you --
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is there anyone
in the administration --
now that Tillerson's out,
is there anyone that you
would like to play?
-Yeah. I want to be
the thug that threatened
Stormy Daniels
in the parking lot.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to be that guy.
There's a lot of ways
you can go with that.
-Yeah.
-You know?
You can get like
the Rudy Giuliani thing,
which is like a second-rate
Tom Hagen.
-Yeah, well, that's the thing.
Because of what we're seeing
as far as the aptitude
of everybody
in this administration,
he might not have been
an effective thug.
Like, he might have been,
like, maybe less thuggish
than a normal guy.
-Yeah.
-He might have gone up
to her and been like,
"Excuse me,
are you Stormy Daniels?"
[ Laughter ]
-"Before you sign this,
could you do me a favor,
just lay off Trump?
I love your work."
[ Laughter ]
-The last time you hosted
that I was there,
I wrote a sketch,
and you were so wonderful.
It did not go to air.
-No.
-It was a hard cut
between dress and air.
-Yeah.
-It was a scene where you
worked at a novelty toy factory.
-Yeah.
-You were the boss.
And there you are.
-You know why the bit died?
-Why?
-That mustache.
-Yeah, you think?
[ Laughter ]
-It was a killer mustache.
And the thing was there
were breakaway chairs.
Because it was
a novelty toy store,
so all the chairs
were breakaway.
-Yeah.
-And Bobby Moynihan
was your employee, and you
kept giving him bad news.
And every time he sat down,
the chair would break.
[ Laughter ]
-"No, try this one."
No, this is good.
-Do you remember Ken Aymong,
who is the producer there?
-Yeah, yeah, Kenny.
-So, Kenny,
I remember when we did it.
He -- Kenny's the guy
who's in charge
of the budget each week.
And he goes, "Pally,
this sketch better work,
because these chairs
cost a fortune."
[ Laughter ]
-Did he use the term "Pally?"
-He did use the term "Pally."
That is a catchphrase
of Ken Aymong.
But you gave it your all.
I take full responsibility.
-I thought it was a great bit.
The audience, not so much.
-No, and it was --
-I think they were taking
a dinner break at the time.
I don't know.
-And you've hosted enough
to know that wasn't like
a maybe/either/or.
Like, it was a minute into
that sketch,
I think everybody involved knew,
okay --
-It's one of those sketches
if you're doing it with
Will Ferrell,
he'd step on the gas.
Not only are we going to crash,
we're going to spread this thing
over three acres.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So, that used to be fun,
like, bombing in a sketch
with him.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah, 'cause it was --
He just -- Rrrrrrrrr!
-Well, that, back when
I had a desk at "SNL,"
like, there was a --
you'd go on the server
and watch old sketches.
And we never watched things
that went well.
We were always like,
"Did you hear the one about
where Will bombed so bad,
nobody in the audience
made a sound and he just, like,
took the longest pauses."
It was like [bleep]
you ass [bleep].
You're staying here all night.
[ Laughter ]
Always so great to see you.
-It was awesome.
-Thanks for everything.